Statecharts add quite a few features. We're going to be looking at
the first two because they're the ones that give the greatest benefit. But
I'll mention also some of the others, okay?
In particular number one thing is statecharts offer nesting or depth, okay?
That is, a particular state in a statechart can be its own state machine.
And you can zoom in that way. Secondly, they offer concurrency. Imagine
that you have two things going on, each of which can have a number of states.
Recall from state transition diagrams that in order to model that we have to
multiply the number of states. Statecharts allow you to treat those separately,
okay? Therefore, only getting an additive number of states rather than
a multiplicative number of states. Of course once you've done that,
that is separated the concurrent machines into two parts, you still have to
synchronize them. That is, they still have to cooperate somehow, and
statecharts offers a way of doing that called broadcast events.
We'll look at that. And of course you could also use data conditions which
are globally available to both machines. We'll look at entry exit actions,
we'll look at event parameters, we'll look at history, and
of course the default states that we've already seen the icons for.